adina has had to flee her home four
times in the last four years this time
the town came under heavy artillery fire
goodbyee there's been a lot of fighting
sleep we have no heat or electricity oh
my husband brought us here but he's gone
back oh lexi is also from of disca he
brought his family and three friends out
of the danger zone a local charity is
paying for their room and board at the
shelter we can stay here till the end of
the week we're told things will settle
down at home but I have to go back to
work right away maybe I can bring my
wife and children to stay with relatives
social organizations in the cities of
kramatorsk and sloviansk not far from
the front lines are working to help
those who have fled of def con natalia
tkachuk has been helping out in the
Donbass region since the onset of
fighting saw the biggest problem is
getting enough food supplies she says we
have nothing local authorities haven't
secured enough funds so volunteers from
other regions have come to help Natalia
kid checks as the government response
was faster this time than a year ago
when F give quitame under fire principe
the authorities are ready to help they
say they will pay all the expenses to
take care of the refugees ciate here's
has about 100 recreational centers but
they're suited to the summer season UN
staff for determining which ones can
accommodate refugees now yucca that had
something to suffice we've looked at a
few of these shelters they need heating
installed in other preparations they're
not suitable yet we have to figure out
exactly how many people's fiat Sahir's
can take in what conditions are like and
what kind of 8 is needed disco ball much
local groups say the town won't be able
to put up more than a thousand people
but the authorities of CIT hairs are
trying to make room for more especially
children the first hundred infants from
abdifatah have already been evacuate
it